On March 11th, Japan was hit by one of the biggest earthquakes the world has ever seen.
The aftershocks and the devastating tsunami that followed...
...have left over 28,000 people dead or missing...
...and half a million people without homes.
In the aftermath, some of Japan's nuclear reactors have experienced meltdowns.
And the whole country is in danger of being exposed to radiation.
Catastrophe of this magnitude almost seems like science fiction but it's not.
It's real, it's very real.
450,000 people are in shelters.
And 1.5 million are without water.
In the face of such adversity, we must unite to help one another.
We must support and help those in need.
Let us unite for Japan.
So 100,000 children can go back to school.
Unite for Japan.
So they can rebuild their country, their community and their spirits.
So that Japan knows that we are supporting them from around the world.
As a global united front, we can make a difference.
Please join now.
Make a donation.
Spread the word to unite for Japan.